if you've got an appetite for a vacation
filled with gorgeous peaches sangria
Under the Sun and a vibrant urban scene
then there's one choice that'll fit the
bill
Spain hi I'm Patti kill more than 50
million people visit Spain every year to
gulp down the sunshine using the art of
bold architecture and the platefuls of
FEA that make up Spain's contagious
passion for living in 1975 after 35
years of general Franco's fascist regime
King Juan Carlos the first took power
and propelled Spain into an era of
freedom and democracy today cities like
the capital Madrid and Barcelona are
cultural centres buzzing with life day
and night
over 2,000 feet Madrid is Europe's
highest capital located here is the
royal palace the largest in Western
Europe it became the royal residence in
1561 was rebuilt after a fire in 1734
and today is used only for ceremonial
purposes Spain's rich history can be
seen all over Madrid from the plaza the
surveillance the Don Quijote to the
Museo del Prado where you'll find works
by Velasquez Jolla and El Greco
northeast of Madrid is Barcelona the
second largest city in Spain as well as
the capital of the autonomous community
of Catalonia in the streets of Barcelona
not only will you hear Catalan as well
as Spanish but you'll also be surrounded
by the work of artists like Beatle
Picasso and gaudi architect Antoni
gaudí's buildings can be seen whole
throughout the city his last project
Sagrada Familia is a massive Church
that's been under construction since
1882 some people expect it to be
completed around 20 41
[Music]
one of the most delectable ways to get a
sense of Spain is through tapas
traditional appetizers that keep you
going until dinner which rarely happens
before 10 p.m.
bullfighting is a fiber deeply woven
into the Spanish cultural tapestry with
origins dating back thousands of years
it is both ritualistic and ceremonial
while protested by some as a cruel
pastime brave souls who wish to
experience bullfighting firsthand should
venture to a Plaza de Toros or bullring
the most famous of which are in Madrid
and Seville where only the best Matadors
are allowed to flaunt their artistry
that's right for fans bullfighting is
not a sport but an art
another deeply Spanish cultural
performance is flamenco flamenco is a
form of song guitar playing and dance
that embodies the complex soul of
Andalusia a region in southern Spain if
you listen closely you can hear Arab
oriental and gypsy influences blending
together to produce this world-renowned
sound and if you're really lucky you
might catch a - of flamenco not on a
stage but in its rise most authentic
form as a spontaneous outburst late at
night in a backstreet bar most experts
believe flamenco originated between the
9th and 14th century when gypsies
arrived from North India via Egypt and
Eastern Europe infuse their music with
cultural arrivals from North Africa
[Music]
in addition to influencing Spanish music
the North African Moorish presence is
made has shaped Andalusia architecture
in granada alhambra derived from the
arabic for red is a palace and fortress
complex built for moorish monarchs the
Mosque in Cordoba so now a Catholic
cathedral once stood as the second
largest mosque in the world
[Music]
wherever your travels may take you in
Spain most likely at every turn you'll
encounter that Spanish spirit a
passionate force with a flair for drama
you